one of the more curious aspects of the
ways we are built is that it can take us
a very long time indeed to work out what
we need in order to be happy
we might assume that the process was
obvious what could be more
straightforward than to want we've
obsessively been doing it since we were
four years old and began a powerful
campaign for an electric train or a set
of farmyard animals
the issue is not that we have no
appetites but that it can take such a
long time for these to become either
accurate or authentic
we start by wanting primarily according
to what others around us want which may
mean that at varied ages we acquire a
bomber jacket a barbecue set a marriage
linen trousers a career in finance a
juicer a divorce
weekly pilates lessons and a six-month
cruise around the pacific
it may be by our fourth or fifth decade
before very gradually we acknowledge
just how unexpected personally flavored
and distinct our characters and
requirements really are and nurture the
courage to do something about it
we might grow honest enough to realize
that we would be happy never again to
see most of the blowhards and fakes we'd
been thinking of as friends and giving
enthusiastic bear hugs to for years and
conversely we might determine that we
now want to hang out exclusively with
people who've had nervous breakdowns
spent time in prison know how to cry and
actively don't give a damn what the
world thinks
we might at the same time realize that
we are bore what news and social media
do to our minds and like a cowardly
sheep finally kicking the farmer delete
everything until our phones can barely
tell the time anymore
we can be proud of all the nonsense that
we no longer have to know about or be
scared of the world will go its own
merry way and we won't have to follow
every part of the bile filled story at
minute intervals
we may also stop trying to impress
people we hate our mother cared
intensely about social status and being
famous and under her aegis we gave up a
great many years of our life
good for her and a pity for us but we're
done with that now and three weird
friends a big dose of misanthropy and a
hut in the woods our beckoning
we are going to be dead pretty soon and
all those cancer stories point us in one
direction only towards the need to stop
being a craven imitative secondhand
timid flunky and heard animal
we need to throw out all the socially
prescribed junk and honor the contours
of our own beautifully unique characters
before it's too late
after a lifetime of imitation fear and
surrender we may finally have to grow a
backbone and become loyal to who we
actually are
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you